Good morning, everyone.
We apologize for the late start.
The regents had a
wonderful opportunity
to have breakfast with a
select number of the faculty
at the University this morning.
And their passion for
students, for where
we're going based on
this strategic plan
was very evident to us.
I think there's a certain
excitement among all of us
at this turning point
for our great university.
So we're going to
focus the entire day
on the operational
and financial review
for the University of Arizona.
The board's scheduled to
meet until 1:00 PM today.
Afterwards, the U of A will host
a strategic reception planning
reception in Old Main.
With that, I'm going to turn
it over to President Robbins.
Good morning, sir.
Good morning.
Thank you, Chairman.
Welcome, everyone.
I have been apologizing
for the cold weather.
But all of a sudden, they
got this room warm enough.
So I'm liking that.
It'll be good.
So, I'm here representing
literally thousands of people.
And in four hours,
we're going to try
to relay to you as regents
and to the greater world what
we've been working on
for the last year--
literally thousands of
people, tens of thousands
of hours that we've worked.
As everybody knows by now,
there are 168 hours in a week.
So use them wisely.
So how this is going to go is
that there are five pillars
to the strategic plan.
We'll cover pillars one and two.
We're getting a little start.
But it was well
worth it as we had
a great breakfast with
the faculty members
and the regents
conversing and exchanging.
Ideas but we'll try to stay
on track and be done by 11:00
and give you a 30
minute break and then
come back and finish off
pillars three, four, and five
and some closing comments.
So, I'm starting out
today to say this
that we are standing on
the shoulders of giants.
And President Schaefer
and President Likins
particular in this picture have
been tremendously helpful to me
and have given
graciously of their time.
I meet with them frequently.
If you ever go to
the football games
and go to the
presidential suite,
you see they sit side by side.
And what you don't see is--
because most of the coaches
have headsets on--
they've got these
little microphones.
And they're actually calling
plays from the press box
up there down to the coaches.
And I saw president Likins here.
Is President Schaefer here?
All right, President
Likins, please stand up.
[APPLAUSE]
We meet every month.
And the beauty for
me is that he just
gives it to me like he sees it.
He's like an umpire, he
calls it as he sees it.
And he's been tremendous help.
We have very scheduled meetings.
President Schaefer
just comes to see me
when he thinks he needs
to tell me something.
And I am incredibly
appreciative to both of them.
And then of course, I had the
incredible, great fortune first
of all, to have this job.
So thanks to the regents
for selecting me.
And I remind the faculty that
all the time-- or they remind
me, they didn't choose me.
But you did.
So thank you.
And President Koffler, I
had almost a year with him.
And we had the same doctor.
So we would sit and
talk about our ailments
in the waiting room.
And his caregiver it
would remind me, at 95,
he was still doing pilates.
And I've yet to find
the gym yet here.
So he was the only alum
ever to hold this office.
And we'll be honoring and
celebrating his life on Monday.
So if you can come to
the memorial service,
that would be great.
And this plan, this
is not my plan.
So I feel somewhat inadequate
here delivering the message
on behalf of literally
thousands of people.
But this plan could
not have been executed
and get to this day without the
tremendous leadership of Lisa
Ordonez and Elliott Cheu.
So in the first
couple of months,
I kind of walked to campus
and listened very carefully.
And I wouldn't say that
two stars are born.
They were already stars.
That's why I selected them.
But I will say that
after this process,
even though they've
gotten beaten up--
and I mean beaten
up, because this
has been a very healthy but
very involved discussion.
And they've been challenged
over and over and over.
And they kept their
eye on the ball.
And so not two new
stars are born,
but their stars are
shining more brightly today
because of this plan so
could you two stand up.
And let's give you applause.
[APPLAUSE]
And this just shows
you we couldn't
get a picture of everybody.
Although, now that I'm thinking
about it, all the things I wish
I had done it was to get
everybody in the mall
and take one of those
pictures from a drone
from above so that you could
see how many people were
really involved.
This is just a collage that
represents the initiative
leaders, the pillar
leads, the deans.
The deans are very,
very important,
because they lead our colleges.
And as I've always said, the
most fundamental academic unit
of any university
is the department.
And the deans look over
departments and lead.
And this just shows a
picture of all the people
who've really put their heart
and soul into this plan.
And I just wanted to thank them.
I wanted to thank others
that are in the room.
But importantly, I want to thank
Brew McKenna who actually took
the bait and has been commuting
back and forth from Houston
to get the band
back together again.
Brew, I hope we don't have to
do this again anytime soon.
But thank you for your help.
And Christine, Katherine,
[? Oneley, ?] Andre, Clare, all
of the people who've been
here every week helping
us to get this plan
together, we couldn't
have done it without you.
And I look forward to the
celebration after this.
I was tempted to
open the presentation
with a little known
one hit wonder band,
the New Radicals, "You
Only Get What You Get."
And it starts out by
saying "wake up, kids,
we've got the
dreamer's disease."
So all these people have
the dreamer's disease.
And we're going to share
with you what our dream is
to try to make the world a
better place through changing
the University of
Arizona and giving us
a roadmap for the next
five 10, 15 years.
So this is actually a picture.
I thought it was a
photo-shopped thing.
But this is actually
a peek at Mt.
Lemon.
And you can see that
wind was blowing
kind of like it was on Monday.
And I think this is symbolic.
And it represents
the mountain that we
have to climb here at
the University of Arizona
for this plan.
And the most difficult
part of this I
kept saying we've got this giant
novel, this classic novel we've
produced.
Here it is right here.
And you all got you know
200 pages worth of our plan.
And the most difficult
part was editing down
for this presentation,
converting a great novel
into a hour and a half
feature motion picture.
So there are a lot of things
that aren't included in here.
It doesn't mean that
they're not important,
but we only have limited time.
And the more I
talk, the less time
we have for you
to ask questions,
which is the most important
part of this presentation.
I'll also say that the
words that we produced here,
the data the thoughts,
that we've collected
are really important.
But what has been
almost as important
has been the journey
that all of us
have been on to reexamine what
is the University of Arizona.
What are our values?
Where are we going?
What's our true north star?
And I think you'll find that
there are some areas where
we're really great.
But there are also
incredible opportunities
as we move forward
to be even better.
So I just want to use
the next couple of slides
to review what I started with
last year in this room at that
my first presentation
at an [? OFR. ?]
And that was to
focus in on rankings.
And I've, as recently as
a couple of weeks ago,
been challenged very viscerally
and very defiantly about
why I talk about rankings.
And we can have that debate.
We're not going to
have it here today
unless you want to get into
it in the question and answer
session.
But I think rankings
really are important.
And I started out last year
by saying we've been flat
over the last few years.
Fortuitously, our
rankings improved.
Just the idea that we're
going to do a plan,
it's like preseason
polls in football.
Just the idea we're going to
have all these star players
shot us up in the poll.
But in all candor, the
methodology for US News & World
Report changed.
And I think it broke to our
advantage, because instead
of giving credit to the
elite for acceptance rate,
that metric was tossed out.
And now universities are getting
credit for graduating Pell
recipients.
And that's right in our sweet
spot, since 35% of our students
are first generation.
We have the largest number of
Pell students that of any AAU.
And we should not
only be proud of that,
but it now plays
to our advantage.
And we only get credit
if they graduate.
So we've got to do a better
job of retaining and graduating
all of our students.
Coincidentally, also
in the rankings,
we made it into the top 50
public universities, which was
sort of a goal that I had set.
I thought both ASU and
the University of Arizona
are such great institutions.
It's just it's a shame,
it's a wasted opportunity
if we're not both ranked in the
top 100 and the top 50 publics.
Now I have to have
to re-gauge that.
I think we need to be top
75 in a top 30 public.
But we'll get to that later.
They'll be the next
strategic plan,
or we'll outperform this one.
And the next couple
of slides are
metrics around retention
graduation rates and research
activity.
Now, for all of you who
really pay attention--
and the regents really
have meticulous attention
to detail--
these slides are off.
The numbers you see on the
right are 15 peer institutions
that we're compared to.
And if you'll
notice that the top,
it's 2017 the data
in the bar graphs.
We have this year's data
compared to last year's data,
the red box is last year's data.
But you know the story.
We're not retaining our
students anywhere close
to where we should be.
As one of the top global
universities based
on our research
productivity and reputation,
our student performance--
as I said last year
and I'll maintain
again this year--
we're just not
where we want to be.
And I think you're going to find
that this is going to be a very
student-centric strategic plan.
We're going to focus on
what our students need,
because we want each and
every one of our students,
no matter where they come from,
what their backgrounds are,
to be successful.
We're here to help our students
realize their hopes and dreams.
And we can't do that if we
can't retain them in school.
Additionally, these
data are two years off.
If you'll see the
bar graph data,
we were at 60% graduation rate.
We've improved over the
last two years, now to 65%.
But in the case of
retention, you'll
see this plan calls for a
91% retention rate and a 75%
graduation rate by 2025.
And it just shows you where
we line up with our peers.
Now, many of you said,
we are very concerned.
We don't think you
can hit these goals.
And I think it will
be a lot of hard work.
We'll have to come
together and work together.
But at the same
time, I would say
they are conservative
goals, because if you
notice the number,
everybody else is
going to be trying to improve.
And even if we hit
our target goals,
we're still going
to be in the lowest
quartile for student success.
But you've got to
start somewhere.
And then on research
activity, this is a graph--
and it's hard to read.
So even with your
pages there, you better
put your reading
glasses on, because it's
a little hard to read.
And I know everyone
in the back can't.
But this is the top 38 research
universities in the country.
And we rank 38th.
Again, the data
lags a little bit.
Our research activity has gone
up over the last couple years
by about $20 million a year.
So I think we're on
a good trajectory.
It clearly is one of the
assets and great things
about the University of Arizona,
it's our research mission.
So it's about both.
It's about student success,
and it's about research.
We're in the knowledge
generation and knowledge
transfer business.
We discover new
knowledge, and we
try to translate
that new knowledge
into commercializible
things that can simply
make the world a better place.
But we also need to educate
the next generation of leaders.
No matter what level
they go into society,
they need the skills
and the education
to be productive members of
their communities and society
writ large.
So we've got both
of these missions.
So over the source of
the many town halls
and the multiple college
departmental meetings
and engaging with the
stakeholders from around
the state and really
our alumni base, which
is around the world,
we also recently did
a survey that was for the campus
community, 15,000 people, which
we got about 4,700
responders too.
But it's very clear.
And it confirms
empirically what you all
told me before I agreed
to come and take this job
and what I've observed
over the last 15 months.
We've got incredibly
strong, talented people
who are highly motivated,
who love this place
and want to come to work
every day and do great things.
Where we have
opportunities is around
holding everyone accountable
for what their job is clearly,
defining which
lane they swim in,
but also managing
them and helping
them succeed in their job.
We also need alignment
around our values.
And I'll talk about
values and pillar five.
But there was clear from the
respondents in the survey
and from the
workshops that we've
done that people are desperate
for a strategic clarity.
What's our true north star?
Where are we going?
And I'm hoping that this
plan begins to address that.
Today is really is the end of
the beginning as we go forward.
The implementation phase that
I'll talk about at the end
is where the real work
is going to happen.
I've said this often.
I stole this from one of
my friends in Australia.
Andrew Forest, "Twiggy,"
I'm giving you credit right
now for this, because
I stole it from you.
But we are a team of champions.
We have incredibly
talented individuals.
What we're seeking to do is
build a championship team.
And that requires
us to work together
to be clearly aligned around
a set of strategic objectives
and then execute on them.
So this is what we're all about.
This is our manifesto,
Regent Myers.
I wasn't allowed to put
manifesto on the slide.
This is our commitment.
This is our contract.
This is our promise to our
students, to our faculty
to all of our stakeholders.
Just parenthetically,
the Checklist Manifesto
developed for aviation and for
medicine, particularly heart
surgery, has saved thousands
and thousands of lives.
So when you said manifesto,
it resonated with me.
But that didn't make
it into the slide deck.
But I want to give you
credit for encouraging
me to call it our manifesto.
This is our public declaration
for where we're going
to go with this university.
And I'll read this
to you, because I
think these are powerful words.
We're going to develop
innovative, adaptive learners
who will go out into the
world to be disruptive
problem solvers who are prepared
to lead meaningful lives
and improve society in this
Fourth Industrial Revolution
economy, improves society,
simply make the world
a better place.
In the second mission
that I talked about around
we're in the knowledge
generation business,
we're going to invest
in the discovery
research and creative
endeavors that
are going to seek to go
out and solve the world's
grand challenges.
And finally, we'll leverage
Arizona's unique assets.
And we are different.
I always used to go around
and look at operating rooms.
And they would say, yeah,
if you've seen one operating
room, you've seen
one operating room,
because they're all different.
They're still operating
rooms, and universities
are universities.
But they all have a
distinctive set of assets.
And I would say the University
of Arizona has a soul.
And that soul is
being reawakened
to focus on we're
in a changing world.
And where we're going will
be captured in this plan,
not totally, but in large part.
And we're going to
use our advantage
of being a diverse population of
people from all over the world.
And we'll use that to leverage
our strengths to integrate
and collaborate with
our partners locally
and around the globe--
the across the street and
around the world approach.
And I think is as the
land grant university
for the Fourth
Industrial Revolution,
this is our manifesto.
So I've talked about the
Fourth Industrial Revolution.
And I remember when
I first arrived--
even before I took the job--
Jeff Goldberg-- Jeff,
thank you for everything
you've done to be a
part of this and to be
a great leader at this
university for over three
decades now and for stepping
in to do the most difficult job
at this university,
which is be the provost.
But I remember you and others
have a book club every month.
And you chose the book, "The
Fourth Industrial Revolution"
in preparation for
me arriving here,
because I'd been
talking about it.
And we had a lively discussion
that day around Halloween
of the world could
you be thinking
of a university in terms of the
Fourth Industrial Revolution
in some small book
that was very dense.
And I remember the
critique of that book
being somewhat brutal.
But anyway, I just wanted to
review the Fourth Industrial
Revolution.
It started with the first
Industrial Revolution
with mechanization,
steam engines,
and automated or mechanized
weaving machines.
And it resulted in the
Luddites who thought,
this is going to be
terrible for the world.
We have to break
into these factories
and destroy these
machines, because our jobs
are going to be taken away.
And we can put an end to this.
We'll just break the machines
and this will all be over.
And it's progressed through
electricity and the Digital
Revolution and then now this
fourth Industrial Revolution,
which is the
convergence of physical
or digital and
biological sciences.
And it's captured in the
book by Klaus Schwab.
And I think it's
worthy of noting
that we shouldn't
be like the Luddites
and be afraid of technology.
We should embrace it.
We should leverage it.
We should use it to
help us learn better,
to do our jobs better,
to be more effective.
And we shouldn't allow
it to destroy society,
to further our gap between
the haves and the have-nots,
but use technology
and the concepts
around the Fourth
Industrial Revolution
to help our societies and
our people be more productive
and do better things.
I also wanted to reference
President Allen's book
Robot-Proof at
Northeastern University.
I think that he captures
many of the guiding
principles of the fourth
Industrial Revolution
and puts it in a context
of higher education.
I really believe that
the University of Arizona
can be the land grant university
in the Fourth Industrial
Revolution.
We've got a chance
to redefine ourselves
in terms of what
our students need
to be prepared to go out
and be competitive for jobs
in this ever-changing,
rapidly-changing world.
And I just put up a couple
of other articles here
about what role the universities
have in the Fourth Industrial
Revolution.
And then the Wall Street
Journal just last week published
an expose on what the Fourth
Industrial Revolution is
and how important it is.
And it's not some
futuristic thing.
We're living it right now.
So we need to be aligning
our research programs
and preparing our students to
be competitive and not only
competitive, but to
thrive in this new world.
So this is a video
that sort of shameless
self promotion of the
University of Arizona
around the fourth
Industrial Revolution.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR (ON VIDEO): We've
done incredible things
at this university.
We've made the moon
landing possible,
the first portable
artificial heart.
And we understand climate
because we know tree rings.
But yesterday's
thinking isn't enough.
We have two jobs--
to prepare our students for
tomorrow that's so different
it's hard to imagine
and to share what
we know to make life better.
Our world is changing
faster than ever.
Lines are blurring.
We are redefining what
it means to be human.
And every decision
has a global impact.
Our students want
to make a difference
but wonder what we can
teach them that they
can't learn on their own.
We need to teach
students how to think.
But to stay relevant,
to outpace the world,
we need to change everything.
By thinking bigger, breaking
routines, and collaborating
more intensely.
Not a single one of us is
exempt from this mind shift.
To prepare disruptive problem
solvers, we must disrupt.
To make the world better,
we must do better together.
ROBERT ROBBINS: So in
this very room last year,
we started talking
about this process.
And over the course
of the last year,
we've had multiple stakeholder
engagement meetings,
like this one that was
captured in this photograph
and also in Phoenix and
have gone around the state.
We've engaged over 10,000
Wildcats in this process.
You've all seen the five
pillars, the first one
being around students.
This is a very
student-centric plan.
The second around
research and discovery,
the third about being
the new land grant
university in this Fourth
Industrial Revolution.
Four will be around are global
and international efforts.
And the fifth pillar
will be around
how we actually run
the university better,
better business processes
more efficiently
to serve our students, our
faculty, and our staff.
This is a slide that I'll
refer back to-- of course,
you can't read it.
Not even in your books
can you hardly read it.
But it just outlines
the over 90 initiatives.
And these were
developed by real people
who were leading them with
groups to design strategies,
tactics to achieve
those strategies,
metrics to measure
success, and identifying
the resource necessarily
to execute this plan.
And you can see just
by the sheer numbers,
this is a very
student-centric plan focused
around the first pillar.
So I'm running behind.
So I'm speeding up a little bit.
And I know that producers
are in my ear telling me,
you're way behind,
you're way behind.
But we started a
little bit late.
And you're going
to get a chance--
and I forgot to
say, at any point--
I'm trying to read
your eyee-- if you
want to ask me a question,
please stop me and ask me.
But I wanted to cover our
goals for student success.
I've already alluded
to them that we're
going to have we're
going to go out
and recruit a very high quality,
high potential student body.
But we're also for
the first time--
and I credit many people
and Vin Dell Casino
and his team and Casey
for thinking about.
Because I thought we need
to raise the quality.
Therefore, we need to lower
the number of students
that we admit to the
University of Arizona,
because we can't grow
to be as big as ASU
or other big
universities, because we
have limited resources.
But I was wrong about that.
They have identified
something that I
believe is going to
be of great service
to the citizens and the
students of Arizona.
And that's focusing
on transfer students,
to focus with our
partners certainly
here at Pima Community College.
But also, I was just out
visiting the Tohono O'odham
Nation, and they've got
a community college there
with nearly 500 students.
And we just haven't
done a good job
of going out and working with
them and helping them do better
and partnering with them.
Coaches Community College,
Vin and his team went down,
and I got a call from the
chancellor thanking us
for coming down.
And of course, Maricopa
Community College,
they're 200,000 students.
And we've just never
focused on these students.
And I think that's something
that I look forward
to watching and helping
build out in this plan.
I said we're going to
have 91%, retention ,
rate 75% six year
graduation rate.
And there are many
different initiatives,
as you saw in that
earlier slide.
They're four that I
wanted to focus on--
general education,
active collaborative
teaching and learning,
student success and retention,
and our honors village.
These are three
quotes that we pulled
from a task force that
was commissioned by Gail
Byrd around general education.
And what it says is
we've had a proliferation
of general education courses.
We've not had proper oversight.
It's very difficult
for our students
to maneuver this system.
And it calls for
reform for us to put
in some central oversight and
structure as we go forward.
Our general education
vision is that we're
going to develop a core
set of courses and themes
that will help our
students be prepared
for this Fourth
Industrial Economy
by studying grand challenges and
looking at driving questions.
The first tenet in
this Wildcat Core is--
and I'll have to
say, there have been
Elliot and Gail and
Vin and Bruce Johnson,
the Dean of Education,
and many others.
You saw 2141, the home that
I am privileged to live in,
we would sit in that great
room and have debates
and discussions and talk about
what is general education need
to be at the
University of Arizona.
Almost every university
is debating this
and struggling with it.
But I want to thank everyone
who's put a lot of effort
and a lot of deliberation in
developing learning outcomes
so we'll know what our
students are learning.
Moreover, we're going to
have professors examining
how effective they are at
teaching and delivering
this information.
We want to develop critical
skills for our students,
so that they'll be
ready to go out and have
the mentality and the tools
to think about design thinking
and coding.
And then a required
first year course
that I'll show you some
of the ideas we have for.
But importantly in that red box,
a central oversight structure
that will give some
clarity to this process.
And we're going to
get right on this.
We're going to start some pilots
in the fall of 2019, including
this first year introductory
bootcamp type course.
So just like Arizona
has the five C's--
I got a lot of pushback
on this, but I got it.
We had some creative
differences with the producers
and directors.
But I got this in.
And this has not
been codified by all
of the experts in
general education.
But I thought it
highlighted what
I had hoped that the core
learning objectives would be--
that our students would
develop critical thinking,
communication both written and
verbal communication skills,
collaborative teamwork
to solve big problems,
have an understanding of the
differences of the world--
because we're in a globally
competitive economy now--
So to have cultural
understanding,
creative problem solving.
These are the five C's
of general education
that I think are important.
Of course, civic engagement,
service back to the community,
there are many other C's
we could add to this list.
One that does not
begin with a c,
we could call
commanding leadership.
Leadership is very important
for our students in my opinion.
So this video, what
I've learned is
that companies like Google
and Amazon and Apple, they
want a hard generalists.
They want students that have
those core skills and values.
And Jeff Bezos was
supposed to be on video.
Actually, he's supposed
to fly in on a drone,
but we got mixed up.
And so we've got Taylor Lawrence
to do this video for us.
TAYLOR LAWRENCE (ON VIDEO):
At present, just over 8%
of all of Raytheon
company's 64,000 employees
hold a degree from
the U of A. Raytheon
will hire more than 260 U
of A grads this year alone.
And we've hired nearly 1,000 of
them from 2014 to the present.
AU students are
consistently up to the task
of tackling some of the
most demanding challenges
in technology and in
advancing and managing
the business the success
of U of A grads at Raytheon
has acted as a catalyst
for the increasingly
important relationship between
our company and the University.
This relationship has an
impact on national security.
It has an impact on
Raytheon's global growth.
It makes us a more
productive company,
because you have
a grads or quality
employees who can
work complex problems
and care about
business outcomes.
The educational institutions,
such as the U of A,
that help prepare students
to compete in these
and other digital fields
will be the schools that
grow their capability faster
and make stronger contributions
to industry and society.
We want to see the
U of A transforming
into the Fourth Industrial
Revolution alongside Raytheon's
own transformation
so that we can
take this partnership to
several next levels together.
ROBERT ROBBINS: So I think that
illustrates the competitive job
market that's out there and
what we need our students
to have a great foundation.
In this first year course
that's being developed,
you can see the things
that we hope that students
will learn as they get ready.
As a pre-medical
student, I was really
focused on physics
and organic chemistry.
And I didn't really
want to take the time
to broaden my horizons with
a liberal arts education.
But I went to a small
liberal arts college,
and it absolutely
changed my life.
And I think our
students, as I've
talked to them, this
big 450 courses,
and how do we've
been maneuver, and we
need to just focus on our
engineering studies and all
the things--
I think we need to slow
the game down, emphasize
that all of these five
C's can be developed
will help you no matter
what you do in your life,
whether you are an
engineer at Raytheon
or you're going to law
school, critical thinking
skills, communication skills,
these fundamental, foundational
skills are so important.
And I'm glad to see
that we're getting
this introduced
into the curriculum
as a pilot in the fall.
Active learning and teaching,
Gail Bird, John Pollock,
Paul Blowers, who you'll see
in a video in just a minute,
have really been national
leaders in this movement
around using the so-called
flipped classroom
for peer-to-peer
mentoring and teaching.
Instead of the sage on stage,
as Shan Sutton calls it,
it's the coach on the sideline
that's helping students
in real time to help
them understand and learn
what they need to do.
Through this
process, people have
started to think we need more
of these flipped classrooms,
and so we're reimagining
the old chemistry
building as an innovative
teaching hub as a possibility.
Whoever lives in there
right now, don't freak out.
This is not-- it's
not decided totally.
But this could be
a place where we
could have a whole building
dedicated to collaborative
teaching and learning.
One of the key points
of this, and I give--
President Schaefer
always said he
wanted to connect the main
library to the engineering
library but Bear Down
Gym was in between,
and he wasn't going
to be the guy who
took down Bear Down Gym.
So Melissa Vito and Shan Sutton
and Vin Del Casino and others
envisioned this idea that we
could build a student success
district.
And I'll show you a video
in the little fly through,
but it'll essentially
be repurposing Bear Down
Gym as a center for
student activities
to help them as a one stop shop
and opening up and connecting
the libraries and putting
another building on the back
to create this vibrant
community where they can go
and they can get advising,
they can do job interviews,
they can have maker
spaces, as you'll
see on one of the slides,
where the traditional library--
yeah, it happens when
I use certain words,
Siri just kicks on.
I don't know how that happens.
But somebody is monitoring me.
But this will be a
transformational differentiated
facility, and the programs that
go on in this student success
district will be like
no other in the US.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SHAN SUTTON: One of
the things that's
really unique about the student
success district design,
it's an intentional design of
four different buildings that
are adjacent to each other
and their outdoor spaces
to create one seamless
student experience.
And this is really
distinctive to the U of A.
We're not aware of any
other university that's
attempted this in terms of
integrating library spaces
and services, as well as
student success, student affairs
spaces and services, so that
students can really easily
move from one space
and service to another.
When you think
about a space, you
have to imagine it as a site
where people come together.
And that's exactly what
we're building here.
And learning is not
a singular pursuit.
Learning always happens in
concert with other people.
So the student
success district is
designed to increase
collaboration between students,
because that peer
to peer learning
is as important, if not
more important than some
of the learning that goes on in
all the other spaces, including
the classroom.
I will share with
you that when I first
came to the
University of Arizona,
I was a very gifted lecturer.
I won lots of awards
in that format,
but students were still
not passing my class.
But lecturing is, in my mind,
is me talking at students,
and the students are
passively receiving
that information of some sort.
And then they watch
me solve an example.
And they go home and they
try to do the homework,
and it looked really
easy when I did it.
Obviously, it isn't.
And so lecturing is one way
of conveying information
to students, but it doesn't
allow for the opportunity of me
to really see what
they're understanding.
And I will say since I moved in
in the collaborative learning
spaces, which really
facilitate the active learning
like this room here,
not a single student
has fallen asleep in my class.
Attendance hovers around
90% to 95% on any given day,
and you don't see that in
lecture hall very often.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ROBERT ROBBINS: So Paul
shared with us in the faculty
breakfast this
morning, first of all,
in the first week
of school last year,
I got to go and
observe Paul teaching
in his collaborative classroom.
I was impressed he knew
every student's name, 100
students in the class he walked
around, called them by name.
And he told me-- and Paul
you can tell me later
if I got this wrong--
but essentially, he
teaches high level,
very difficult
chemical engineering
course that he
said before changing to this
active collaborative style
around half of the students
could pass or either finish
his course.
And now over 90% of students
finish his course successfully.
So I think that's a testament
not only to his ability and his
seeing the future and changing
his pedagogical approach,
but it also says a lot
about him as a person.
He shared with us
this morning that he
went to a high school that
didn't even offer trigonometry,
and now he's one of our
most esteemed professors
of this university.
And he and so many
of our faculty staff
care about our students and
want to see success for each
and every one of our students.
So the libraries, the new
student success district,
very impressive buildings.
But what goes on
in the buildings,
I think, will be more important
than the buildings themselves.
There are programs around
first cats for first generation
students that have more
than 90% retention rates.
New Start just
celebrated 50 years
of helping students, primarily
from our Latino and Hispanic
communities, and that program
where they come for six weeks
before school starts
that first semester
and they get to live in the dorm
and they get to take classes
and they get to go
to this boot camp
and get ready for college--
50 years into this, the
retention rate in that program
is 90%.
And I said, why don't we
do this for every student?
Well, this costs money
and requires resources,
but this is absolutely the
meticulous attention to detail
that we need to have
for all of our students
if we're going to get out
of that bottom quartile
with our peers.
And then finally
in this session,
I wanted to just talk
about the Honors Village.
I think Dean Hunt in recruiting
Associate Deans John Pollard
and Melissa Fitch
are really developing
an exciting new curriculum
and new direction
for our honors students.
And this building facility,
this complex, this village
will be as good if not the best
in the country that currently
will be scheduled to
be open for students
in the fall of next year.
And so if you walk through it--
I have to point on this screen--
but the dorm rooms are here.
Yeah, I don't have a laser.
You can see it.
Dorm rooms in the red.
And then all of the activities
that are currently spread out
across the campus
will be centralized
in this one village with a rec
center, with a dining hall,
with all the classrooms, and
the administrative offices
being in this one village.
So our students can
get this high touch,
highly directed
liberal arts experience
inside this large
research university.
And you can go to
football games.
Please come on Saturday
after Thanksgiving.
I know maybe we won't have
a lot of students here
but a big game.
We're going to have
to beat Arizona State,
I think, to get to a bowl game.
So it's going to be good.
But you can have this incredible
liberal arts experience
by some of our master
professors like Paul Blowers,
like our regents
professors, people who are--
Dante, who you'll see on a
video in the next section who's
leading the OSIRIS-REX program,
leaders from our health
sciences, come in and talk to
our students about their life
and about how important it it
is to get real life experience
and also combine that with
a liberal arts education.
That's it.
I'm finished with
the first section.
So your question, your
timing is perfect.
I'm also 20 minutes
behind time, but that's--
AUDIENCE: OK, Honors
Village, so you're
recruiting right now for
honor students in the Honors
Village for fall 19.
Yes.
So recruiting students without
facilities to show them, yeah.
What are you anticipating
the enrollment
will be first year there?
Well, I think, we have
an Honors College now,
and we have about
1,000 students.
And so I am confident that we're
going to have 1,000 students.
The difference I
think is we're going
to have many more highly
qualified students than we
potentially can accommodate.
And I know that
Dean Hunt is looking
at raising the bar for what
it means to be an honor
student at the
University of Arizona,
and I think that's a good thing.
So we are starting
to think about how
we're going to market
this new village
and also not just
the new village
but the programs that will
go on inside the village.
I mean, Terry's only been
here a year, and I think he--
and he's putting his team
together and thinking
about what are the
differentiated type of programs
and curriculum and seminars and
experiences that will go on.
What's traditionally gone on
here at our Honors College,
because it's been spread
out all over the campuses,
you go for the first
year, you live in a dorm,
and then there's not a
lot of connectivity back.
I think this new village with
rec center and food and seminar
series and things going on
in that beautiful green space
and the quad inside
of it, I hope
our honor students will stay
connected for all four years.
AUDIENCE: Is the anticipation
that it would only be
freshman in the dorm, though?
ROBERT ROBBINS: It would be
only freshmen in the dorm,
but there is enough leeway that
if you want to stay in the dorm
then I think that you
can be accommodated.
But traditionally, that's
what the model has been.
And that gets me
into another thing
about I think all
of our students
should want to live on campus.
We don't have enough
dormitory rooms now,
but we need to build more.
I also think that we need right
alongside the Honors Village,
the next project I think is
going to be focused on building
a graduate student
village that would serve
the graduate students
who are incredibly
important to this university.
And I'll get into that more on
the research side of things.
But we need to invest in
our graduate students.
They're so important to the
success of the university.
So giving them a place that
would be sort of out in front
of Eller, so they could--
they could live there and go
across the street
and go to Eller
or the law school or engineering
or the health sciences,
I think that's going
to be really important.
And at least from the focus
groups I've done with students,
would be quite positive
in terms of the desire
to want to live there.
But we've got to
look at expenses.
People live off campus now,
because we charge them too much
to live on campus.
So we're looking at
that and the possibility
of building new dorms.
So I think the health
of a university
is indirectly measured by how
many students want to stay
on campus all four years.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank
you, Dr. Robbins.
I just want to go back
to the beginning of this,
and I wanted to compliment
you and the entire team.
Your manifesto, as
you said, but I see
this is such a great platform--
the whole idea of the
fourth industrial revolution
and the idea that
it's a changing world.
And while we're going to spend
the rest of the day going
through a lot of the particulars
of what you've come up
with already, kind of, the
most important thing to me
is the recognition that we
don't know what's going to come,
but we're going to help
shape what that is.
And U of A's going
to play a key role.
And I think the whole
underpinnings of this
is the idea of U of A being
a leadership university,
being a leadership entity
in this state and the world
and unleashing that power
of the people of U of A
to go make that happen.
So I just want to
congratulate the whole team
on the fundamental
way you started this.
The details are
great, and the details
will change over time as
people come up with new ideas.
But putting that
challenge in place
and starting from that
position, I think is great,
and it's what a great
university should do.
So thank you.
ROBERT ROBBINS: Thank you for
your nine years of guiding
this this whole enterprise,
but particularly living down
here and all the things you've
done for the community here
and pushing me.
I mean, they're very kind words.
When we're off camera
you challenge us,
and I appreciate that.
And I appreciate this
process of the give and take
and the challenge.
And we're not we're not
finished with this yet.
As I said, this is the
end of the beginning.
And so I look forward even
when the governor does finally
put someone in the game--
I think what they do
on the football field,
you see him patting their head.
That means I want to come out
of the game, because I'm tired.
Maybe you need to send a
video patting your head,
and so the governor will
get you some relief.
But you're going to remain
involved because you live here,
and we greatly appreciate
all your help on this.
We can't move on,
because we haven't
spent enough time on the clock.
We still have more
time for questions,
but I'm happy to move on
because that means I get
more time on the research side.
AUDIENCE: Faster,
funnier, great.
Yeah, OK.
AUDIENCE: Move on.
Well, we had a chance to
meet with each one of you
over the past few months and,
kind of, bring you along.
And we had a-- we had a good
exchange yesterday morning
about some of the important
parts of this plan.
So I'll keep going
on, and we'll move now
into the research and discovery
side, another important mission
for the university.
And I would say--
I don't love President
Schaefer made it here,
but when I talked
to and I've visited
with every one of
my predecessors
and they all pointed
to President Schaefer
being the transformational
president of this university.
He got us on the
right pathway, and I
think he was probably 37
when he started as president.
I don't know if he's here.
Did he make it?
President Schaefer, thank
you very much for being here
and all the guidance
you've given me.
[APPLAUSE]
And there he and
President Likins
are sitting, scheming
about how they're
going to beat the pirate
up at Washington State
this weekend in football.
But I do think it
was an important time
for the university, and the
beauty is he's a scientist
but at the same time
focused on the arts,
created the Center for Creative
Photography, the Poetry
Center, which is one
of the great poetry
centers in this country.
So we have a lot
too-- and I personally
have a lot to owe to both
he and President Likins
for being around.
And I can just go they're not
many people, and President Crow
and I talk about this all the
time, these are hard jobs.
And there are not many
people who understand.
Regent Penley, certainly,
is somebody that I can go to
and understands what
the complexities
and challenges of this job are.
But I've really appreciated
all of the guidance and support
I've gotten in the short
time I've been here.
And hope to be here
for a long time.
So one of the things that
makes this university great,
and if you look at
why we're consistently
ranked in the top
100 universities
on all global rankings--
I think this year, we were
by one of the rankings
ranked 16th worldwide--
is because of our
research productivity.
And we, of course, want
to continue to invest
in our research enterprise.
I think it gives--
one of the things
that is a little
different about the
University of Arizona
and from the previous
strategic plan
that President Hart put
together is 100% engagement.
I think that's fantastic.
And the opportunity for
undergrads on this campus
to be involved and
to actually-- you'll
see Dante talk about this
in the OSIRIS-REX project
to actually be part of that
and do research and understand
how the research that they do
either in the health sciences
center are in engineering
or in the environment
or at the biosphere affects the
bigger picture of the world,
I think is one of the
differentiating parts
of the university and
it keeps us competitive.
So even though
we're ranked 38th,
I am absolutely confident
that we can do better
and that we can be a top
25 research university.
You see in the
third bullet point
that we want to be a top
25 health sciences research
center.
Currently, we're ranked 54th.
I think that's
where there's going
to be a lot of opportunity
moving forward in the world
as we move into this fourth
industrial revolution.
But I think specifically
because of the University
of Arizona's assets--
not the least of which is
we have two medical schools,
great pharmacy, nursing,
and public health--
but also we've got a clinical
partner in Banner that I think
will help us get to
move up to the rankings.
And I'm confident
we can hit our goals
and actually exceed
our goals that we
have for our research goal.
So we say that we want
to hit $800 million
in research activity by 2025.
I think this is one
of the few goals--
the ABOR goals that we're
actually saying we're
going to exceed.
Because I think
it's $752 million
was the original ABOR goal
or the revised ABOR goal.
Maybe it was $1.2 billion, and
someone got some reality check
and moved it back to $750.
So I think this is
a reasonable goal.
But if you go back to that
slide of the 38 top research
universities, what I would
love to be able to do
is be here long enough to
hit the billion dollar mark.
I think that our endowment
needs to be about $800
plus million dollars.
Now it needs to be
about $2 billion,
and we need to have $1
billion in research activity.
And I absolutely believe
we could hit that.
By 2025, I think we'll
hit the $800 million
for all the reasons I've said.
And there's no
magic formula there.
I've been told that you all
want to hear exactly how we're
going to get there.
We're going to get there
one grant at a time.
We're going to recruit
and retain star faculty
from all over the world.
We have the facilities,
we have the mentality,
we've got great
weather, great culture.
There's a soul to this place
that people want to be here.
And that's how we're going
to win research grants.
And we've got to do a
better job of recruiting
faculty members from all walks
of life and all backgrounds.
And as I've said
before, our diversity
at this university
especially as we
go into this globally
competitive fourth industrial
revolution economy
is going to be
one of the great strengths
of this university.
Equally, we've got to
attract great grad students
and professional students.
But the graduate
students are the students
of how this actually works
is brilliant professors will
conceive of and write grants
and go out and win the grants,
and who does the work actually?
Our graduate students, our
undergraduate students,
our postdocs.
That's how this
whole thing works.
So we've got to
double down, invest,
and support our
graduate students
not only in the
research side but also
allow them to get
in the classroom
and to teach our undergrads.
Because many of them
if we can't begin
to change the quality of our
teaching by our professors,
because most of
the time you're not
taught actually how to teach.
And we've got a
great opportunity,
and I think Gail and
her team and others
are thinking about how we do
evaluations of our professors.
This didn't go over very
well, but I suggested, well,
we videotape them.
And we get a quality control
person just like the NFL has,
and we look at everything
they talk about
and you give them
positive feedback.
I don't know that we're
there yet on that idea,
but the idea is we need to
start with our graduate students
and teaching them how to teach
and give them the opportunity
to teach.
And then finally,
it's really important
to have the facilities to
be able to do this work
and to be able when you
put a grant in there's
always an environmental and
facilities part of any grant
application.
And the funding
agencies want to know
that if they give you the
money to do this work,
you're actually going to have
the facilities, the equipment,
the infrastructure in place and
mostly the intellectual talent
to be able to be successful
and advance science and have
new discoveries
for the betterment
of our state, our country,
and indeed the world.
So this part of the
plan, we'll get into it
in pillar three
around our service
to the state, our
stewardship back,
what's in it for the state
when they invest in us.
And economic
development is clearly
one of the great multipliers of
being located near a research
university.
I think if you look at
the economics of it,
it's about a 3.4
multiplier on how
communities around great
research universities
develop their economies.
And you saw Taylor
Lawrence in Raytheon.
I mean, their world
headquarters is outside Boston,
but their missile
defense business is here.
And what Taylor
always tells me, I
ask him what can we do for you.
He said keep
producing engineers,
but keep producing engineers
that have those core five Cs
that when they hit the
ground running here ,
they know how to work in teams,
they know how to be leaders,
they know how to communicate
and how to critically think.
So this is how we're going
to get to that 800 number,
and I think we've got the
opportunity to do even better.
These are the areas--
again, this is
somewhat sensitive,
because I can remember when
we were doing a strategic plan
at Stanford and it came
down to the final cut
and I was lobbying the
president very hard
that cardiovascular diseases
kill more people than anything
else in the World.
Cancer now does, because
we've done better mitigating
cardiovascular disease.
But at the final cut,
neurosciences in stem cell
biology made it and
cardiovascular didn't, so I
was really disappointed.
But it didn't stop me
from raising money, doing
our research, and
running our institute.
And it won't stop.
If I don't mention the
discipline that you work in,
it doesn't mean that
it's not important.
But these are the things that
we're really going to focus on.
The first area is around space.
I mean, we've got to
be able to continue
to invest in the things
that made us great,
that got us to where we are,
and we'll continue to do it.
And it just so happens there's
great opportunity around space.
Around human
health, it's obvious
that that's going to be one of
the world's great challenges--
not only in the
science side of thing
but also in policy
and societal issues.
Data computer and
network science,
it's the fundamental platform
of the fourth industrial
revolution.
We've got to be good at that.
We've also got to incorporate
humanities into this,
and then finally the
environment is so important
that we at the University have
the institute the environment,
over 300 researchers
that are focused here.
And we're one of the
great universities
around environmental studies and
particularly around arid lands.
So for space, there are many
things that we can focus on,
not the least of which
would be exploration, what's
out there, what are the
origins of the universe,
how did we all get here.
When you start
thinking you're all
that, just remember we're
just one little speck
in that big universe out there.
And there was a
recent article, and I
was going to have a fly
through here about it
because it was so timely
about Harvard professor see
moving object that's
accelerating and decelerating.
And they think that it's a
spaceship from another galaxy
or another universe
coming to say hello to us
and explore with us.
Well, I'm not really sure.
We can ask the real experts
who do rocket science what
they think about it.
But I think the point
is we're out there,
the whole OSIRIS-REX
project is trying
to sample this
asteroid, Bennu, and try
to get an analysis of what
the origins of the universe
and how we got here
and what's out there.
We've got telescopes to the
north, east, west, south,
and that's why
we're so good here.
I asked why are we so good
at astronomy and planetary
sciences?
It's because we've
got great weather.
325 nights out of the year,
you've got a beautiful portal
into the universe.
The other one is around
using satellites and imaging
to help things on
Earth, particularly,
around watching around crops and
water and other things that'll
be turning back on Earth.
That great picture-- the
first picture of Earth
was from our team here
as we were scouting out
places for the first
landing on the moon,
and then the rogue professor
who was told he could only
take pictures of the moon at the
last minute turned the camera
and took a picture of
the Earth, and it was
the first picture of the Earth.
So there are a lot of things
that we can do in the space
environment, and I
would say, as I'll
talk about in the third pillar,
some potential partnerships we
can do.
But the business of space,
which I didn't really
understand until we
got into this process
about doing asteroid
mining for precious metals,
that seems a very, a
very low margin business.
But as President Crow and
I were talking about it,
this is something that is--
it's a real thing, and I think
we're going to see it happen.
I had some venture
capitalists from Palo Alto
recently tell me that
their fund is only
investing in the
business of space,
and did I know that if
you produced optic cable
for telecommunications
in microgravity
that it's like 10x
more efficient?
Again, I think a very
low margin business,
but people are thinking
about this stuff.
The one that Dean
Wakene Ruiz told me
about the other day-- which I'm
now starting to get onto it--
is we've got a company
here that you'll
hear about in a video called
Vector who just figured out
how to launch satellites at low
cost, a relatively low cost.
Probably the size of this to put
these satellites out and circle
the entire earth so that
you could send signals
from anywhere on earth
constantly and think
about using those satellites
as a part of a series
of computers, the so-called
blockchain for cybersecurity
or for data management.
This is the kind
of business that I
think that we not only here
at the University of Arizona
and southern Arizona
but the entire state
are poised to take advantage of.
So this is Dante
Lauretta who is the--
who is just an
incredible individual who
leads the OSIRIS-REX program.
One of the first
missions that NASA ever
entrusted to someone
other than NASA to do,
and the University of
Arizona is doing this
and has done another--
is run another project.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
There is an enormous benefit
to our faculty, to our staff,
and to our students to be
leading a NASA mission like
Osiris-REx.
It allows really
highly talented people
to be attracted to
our institution,
both in the faculty, but
also in our engineering
staff and our support services.
It's been a great educational
experience for our students,
working hands on a Osiris
REx since we started
conceiving of the mission.
These are real jobs with real
resume-building experience,
and our students have
gone off to great careers
in space, engineering,
management,
and many other disciplines.
Just in Tucson,
we have companies
ranging from Raytheon Missile
Systems to World View,
doing ballooning at the
edge of space that is really
space missions, to
Vector, that is launching
small satellites
into space, something
that nobody ever was
able to do before.
These are the
kinds of companies,
and the companies that will
come with them, that we
want to work with.
We need to become
proactive in promoting
the University of Arizona.
Making sure not only
does the city of Tucson
know about the amazing
things that we do here,
but that reverberates throughout
the United States, Washington
DC, and even worldwide.
[PLAYBACK ENDS]
So I think everyone here
knows about how good we are
in space science and astronomy.
I think we can even do better.
And you'll see a couple
of my thoughts in Pillar 3
when we come back
from our break.
I want to move on to one of
the other parts of our research
portfolio and initiatives.
And that, of course,
is human health.
And you can see
to the right there
the incredible amount
of opportunities
we have across this campus,
certainly south of Speedway,
to work with the
different colleges
here, whether it's
optical sciences--
And I have to say,
optical sciences
is just an incredible program
that Tom Koch and others
have built here over the years.
And they probably
have more partnerships
and do more economic
development for this region
by working with
Fortune 50 companies.
And so we're incredibly
lucky to have them,
and you're going to hear
some more really good news
coming out of optical science
in the coming weeks to months.
And I'll show you
a building that'll
be built in their
neighborhood that we've heard
about at committee meetings.
But the opportunity for our
health sciences programs
to collaborate across the
other colleges is tremendous.
And I think it's one of the
great advantages we have
by having two medical schools
and the other health sciences
colleges partnered with Banner.
If you look across the
United States in communities
of a million and
less, unless you
have an academic medical
center in that smaller
population and that
catchment area,
then without having a partner,
you're going to struggle.
And I know that the
partnership with Banner
was something that
was very difficult,
and it was born out of a
time of necessity and need.
But I think it's
going to turn out
to be one of our great
competitive advantages
as we look forward, to
have a system that's
the seventh largest
in the United States.
And to be able to leverage
all of these technologies,
and to really change
the way that health care
and medicine and
wellness are delivered,
I think are a
competitive advantage.
Much of that is going to be
focused around data and data
management.
Hence why I keep talking
about the fourth Industrial
Revolution so much.
And as you can see, the
collaborative boxes there.
You know, BIO5, as I
often tell Tom Keating,
BIO5 was the fourth
Industrial Revolution
before the fourth Industrial
Revolution was ever
conceived of by Klaus Schwab.
Also, Shane Burgess, our
vise president for College
of Agriculture
and Life Sciences.
I mean, he was onto
this a long time ago.
And when I was giving
a talk and said,
just imagine that in
the future, farmers
will have these fleets of
drones that will go out
and assess their property,
and assess their crops,
and use data analysis.
He said, we were on
to that 10 years ago.
So Shane and Jennifer
Barton and others
that are around
the university who
are running these big operations
really understand this.
And I think the new veterinary
school that we're starting.
And we have a dean.
I think Jeff has made an offer,
and hopefully she's accepted
and will start in January.
It's very exciting for us,
because it combines this one
health concept that goes
all the way from the farms,
and the ranches, and not
only crops and livestock
with our incredible
land grant mission
of cooperative extension and
helping farmers and ranchers.
But while we're
there, we can also
be talking to them
and their families
about their personal health.
One of the areas that we have
great strength with here,
in addition to the artificial
heart you saw in the video,
is telemedicine.
One of the experts
in telemedicine
came to the University of
Arizona over 30 years ago
and got that program started.
And that's going
to be, Mike Dake
has come to lead the
Health Sciences Center.
And I'm incredibly grateful.
He also wanted to get the
band back together here
in the desert.
And I think he's doing a
tremendous job with some
of the people like
Larry Goldberg that's
been hired by Banner to be the
CEO over the Academic Medical
Center's side.
I think their partnership
has allowed us to now start
talking about these
transformative,
fundamental discoveries
that can be made across all
of our colleges, and
incorporated into redefining
the future of health
care and wellness care.
So the three areas that
the health sciences
have chosen to focus
on around unlocking
the mysteries of the
future health puzzles
are around the brain.
Obviously, we're very
good at neuroscience.
If you look south of
Speedway, John Hildebrand,
Linda Dale, Carol
Barnes, who is one
of the most gifted
neuroscientists in the country,
have tremendous neuroscience
programs on the main campus,
if you will.
And then the recruitment of
Robbie Brinton and others
on the north side of Speedway.
Bringing those groups together,
along with Eric Reiman,
who is in Phoenix, who is
a world's expert along with
Robbie Brinton on
dementia and Alzheimer's.
This is a powerful
group of investigators
that can come together
and help unlock some
of the mysteries of why
people get dementia.
We still don't know, what are
we going to do with our aging
population?
By 2030, this country will
be spending $20 trillion--
that's a t, not a b--
$20 trillion on the
care of individuals
with cognitive
dysfunction, dementia,
and Alzheimer's disease.
So we need to learn how to
help our individuals age
and have better quality of life,
and how to take care of them.
I think a lot of this is
going to happen because we're
doing a better job of
mitigating the ravages of cancer
through the second bullet, which
is immunobiology for cancer
and the entire immune system.
Remember, we just mapped
the whole human genome
about 15 years ago.
It took 10 years and
billions of dollars.
If we were going to invest in
the next big thing like that,
it would be a human
immunome project.
Because your immune system,
from fighting infections
and emerging pathogens
in the world,
to turning your
immune system on-- we
all get cancer every
day in our bodies.
Our immune system find
those cancers and kill them.
So by definition, if
you develop cancer,
you've got some dysfunction
of your immune system,
compared, or in concert
with, your genetics.
And your environment.
If you smoke, for
instance, you're
at a higher risk of lung cancer.
But your immune system has
to fight those cancer cells.
And the Nobel Prize
for Medicine was just
won by Jim Allison at M.D.
Anderson for this work.
So I'm glad to see that this
area of discovery and treatment
and diagnosis made
it into the plan.
And then finally,
we were awarded
one of the largest
precision medicine grants
in the country's history.
$48 million.
And they thought we're
doing such a good job,
they increased it
to $60 million,
which never happens
from funding agencies.
But we clearly have a great
strength in precision health,
genomics, proteomics,
metabolomics.
And the reason we got
that grant, in my opinion
as an outsider at
that point going, wow.
University of Arizona.
They're punching above
their weight there.
Why is it?
Two factors, I believe.
Well, three.
One, we've got great
scientists who do great work.
We've got a diverse
population of patients,
with a large Hispanic-Latino,
large Native American
population, that makes these
data important and interesting.
And then the final one is
because we have Banner.
We've got a system to be
able to recruit patients,
and deliver care, and answer
some of these questions because
of our partnership with Banner.
So I think that those are
three important pillars
in the strategic plan.
Stem cells didn't
make it in there.
That's my particular area.
And I really like stem cells.
But I couldn't lobby hard enough
to get stem cells in there.
So twice in these strategic
planning processes,
I've lost out.
But at the end, we're
all going to be winners.
After, as I said, this is
the end of the beginning
part of this process.
And I'm thankful that
when Mike came here
that he pushed hard on what they
need to be part of this plan.
I was just looking for
some collaborative projects
across Speedway, north
of Speedway, that
could be part of this plan.
But he pushed me really
hard to say no, we
need to have a full-on strategic
plan for the health sciences
that incorporates into
the main campus plan.
So this idea that there
are two different plans,
I really don't like.
This is one plan.
And the health sciences
are a big part,
just like the environment
and planetary sciences
and astronomy are.
But there is a need
going forward for Banner,
now that Larry Goldberg and
Mike Dake have been here
for almost a year, that we do
need to partner with Banner
to do an in-depth strategic
plan for the clinical part
of the operation.
But integrating the teaching and
research mission and discovery
mission of the university
into the culture of Banner.
So this is the first time
that Banner has really gotten
involved in academic medicine.
And it's not like running
all of their other hospitals.
That's clear.
Secondly, our physicians
and our staff--
there's a rigor.
And the world is changing
to focus on protocols
and, dare I say, artificial
intelligence and machine
learning algorithms.
And we've got to be
up to speed together
as we advance those technologies
to simply take care of patients
better and improve our outcomes.
But at the same time, fulfill
our education and research
mission.
So there will be another
plan that we'll come back
to present to you which is the
combined Banner U of A health
sciences plan.
I wanted to sneak
in a commercial.
Maybe I could do
it at the break.
They'll kill me for this, but
I don't know if any of you
have seen the advertisement
that U of A Banner
has that I saw when I was
watching the local Fox
affiliates and watching a
football game on Saturday.
It's outstanding.
And maybe I'll stimulate
you to go look it up.
So we'll have a plan
that we'll come back--
and I think it's really going
to be important-- that'll
focus on what service lines,
what's the length of stay, how
we're doing on our
customer service,
patient service surveys.
How we're investing
the resources together
to get the hospitals profitable.
When we started, it was about
a million dollars year deficit.
And I hear we're down to
about $60 million a year,
and maybe $20 million next
year, and break even the year
after that.
I'm very confident with the
team that we have in place
that we'll get there.
And then we need to build out
the Phoenix Biomedical Campus.
Not only with our partner
institutions, but Banner's
flagship hospital is there.
So you'll see a lot more
to come about what--
one of the reasons, I
think, primary reasons
that to all hired me, was
to help focus on this.
And at this point, I'm
excited about what's
in the strategic
plan, but equally
excited about what's going
to come in the future.
So this is a new
college initiative 2.5.
It's very robust.
And it calls for the
creation of a college of data
computing and network science.
Anytime you start talking
about changing the curriculum
or starting new colleges,
the faculty and the deans
get very concerned,
and tell me I'm going
from preaching to meddling now.
But I think that--
and of course, we've got to
go through all of the steps
to make this a reality--
but I really think
this is something
that if we're going
to be the land grant
university for the fourth
Industrial Revolution,
it's my opinion
that establishing
a college like this, and
making it a college because
of the last bullet
point down there,
which is attracting students.
And we could have all
of these activities
go on in all the colleges.
But I think to have it
in one central location,
so that these programs and
professors and students are
centralized, and are being
prepared for not only
our research activities.
It's sort of the
idea of the center
of a sunflower with petals
coming out of the center.
Data computing, network
and quantum computing,
are going to be fundamental
platform technologies that will
support the health sciences.
A big part of this
is going to be
around artificial
intelligence, machine learning
algorithms, quantum computing.
And medicine is
moving very rapidly.
Siemens, GE, Philips are
investing billions of dollars
in algorithms that will
help to interpret CT scans.
Pictures of
dermatological lesions.
Pictures of histopathology.
Pap smears single cell cells.
Is this a cancer?
Yes, no.
And the way that's
done is to compare
10 million normal pictures
or images to 10 million
with malignant melanoma, or
small cell cancer of the lung.
I think this, along
with interacting
with our world-renowned
MIS program
in Eller; with Shane
Burgess and all
of the incredible
opportunities in agriculture;
with our engineering
college; with humanities,
because of the opportunities
around digital humanities,
and using, as we heard this
morning, using technology
to help students learn better.
No matter what discipline it is.
I think this is going
to be really important.
And it brings together and
connects some of the things
that we have.
SciVerse is a huge--
that came out of [? Cals. ?] I
think the signature program was
sequencing the rice genome.
It's now moved into
one of the largest data
repositories in the world.
Putting all these
assets together
I think is going to be an
important part in the evolution
of the university.
Regent Myers.
Maybe using this
as an example.
I mean, this is
all very exciting
that you're talking about.
But when we leave
today, this wants
to accelerate, not slow down.
And maybe using
this as an example,
how do you accelerate it?
How do you drive the
execution in a way
that we're going to see
these things materialize
in the short term,
not the long term?
At the end, I'll have
a slide about that.
As I keep saying, this is
the end of the beginning.
The most important
part-- it's great to have
these great ideas.
I love the idea of
being a futurist.
Because the only thing you do
is just predict the future.
You don't ever have
to make it happen.
And so the idea that we've
pulled this vision together.
And it's more than just the
slides and the four hours
that we have today.
It's all that's in
here, and even more.
It's the implementation phase.
We've got to be
able to execute it.
We've got to have the
discipline to stay at this.
And it's-- excuse me--
not going to be easy.
It's going to be a lot of work.
But we have to have processes,
and structure, and people,
and resources in
place that will focus
on the execution of each
one of these initiatives.
Not only executing the
strategy, but devising
existing or new tactics to
help us to achieve those goals.
But also metrics
to define success,
because you can't change
what you don't measure.
And then finally,
the resources that'll
be needed to build on this.
But as a trailer to the
end of the presentation,
we will come back
to you every quarter
and tell you,
initiative by initiative
on those 90-plus
initiatives, where we are,
and give you an update.
And you'll hold us accountable.
It'll be transparent.
And we'll all be rowing
in the same direction.
LARRY PENLEY: President
Robbins, perhaps you're
going to answer Rick Meyer's
question in the way you've just
described.
But let me just phrase
it a different way.
But also just say to you
before I ask the question
that all of us appreciate the
engagement that you've really
had with this strategic plan.
You talked about
that at the beginning
with all of the constituents
that you've worked with.
But you have, as you
noted, engaged each of us
along the way in
the strategic plan.
And I think that's
just really well done.
I think as well, you've
presented something here
that has a multi-year process,
as you're pointing out,
associated with it.
It's not a strategic
plan for next year,
it's a strategic plan for the
longer run for the university.
And I think that's admirable.
But in the end--
and this is the tough
part, and you and I
have talked about
this at times--
all of us want you
to do something
in our area, whatever
that area is.
But in order to achieve this
plan, choices must be made.
Priorities must be set.
Strategic imperatives for
this year and next year
must be selected.
In some ways, what you've done
so far in the presentation
is to make it clear that
one of the imperatives
is a reorganization.
And that is this college that
you've just been talking about.
And I applaud the college.
I think it makes a
great deal of sense.
Having come from the
academy, none of us
like disruption
in organizations.
We all like stability so that
we can teach our students
and do our research.
On the other hand, as
the environment changes,
the organization has to
change as well if it's
going to accomplish what
it needs to down the road
in the future.
So this appears to be
one of those imperatives
that you're choosing at
this particular point.
In what you've done so
far, both in talking
about the kind of student
body you need to put together
and in terms of the importance
of certain research areas
for this institution, what are
some of the other imperatives
that you've identified
so far that really
must be done immediately?
Well, I think we've come all
the way to the 11th hour here
to get this plan together,
And there's still
discussions and negotiations
going on, and thinking about.
For instance, there's
a whole set of colleges
that we could establish.
And I think I'm eagerly
awaiting a report
from an external review of our
Institute of the Environment.
One of the individuals that
served on that committee
used to be here.
He was recruited to the
University of Washington
to establish a college for
environmental sciences,
for instance.
Could we have the
discussion about creating
a college of
environmental sciences
here with students that go to
many different colleges now?
That's an example.
So I think there are other
examples around what model
we're going to deliver
this new structured part
of general education.
Should that be in a college?
Should it be run
through a program?
Should we combine the college
of science, humanities,
social and behavioral
science, and fine arts
into a mega college
of arts and sciences?
These are all
questions that will
have to be answered in the
coming weeks to months.
But I think that we'll have
those answers very shortly.
Because when we start
deploying resources,
that's when we'll
have the answer.
And at the end, I'll
also get into where do we
get the resources from.
How could we possibly
do this and how could we
fund this plan.
So important, very
difficult questions.
I think that certainly, if
we look to Arizona State,
President Crow has done an
incredible job of creating
new colleges and
moving people around.
We have a different
culture here.
So to be able to do
something like this
in this strong culture of shared
governance and the traditions
that we have at
the University here
is going to take a lot of work.
But I'm convinced that
this one in particular,
if we're building the
whole plan around the idea
that we're going to
be the land grant
institution for the fourth
Industrial Revolution.
I think back to, what were
Oxford and Cambridge thinking
about during the first
Industrial Revolution
when the Luddites were
breaking windows and breaking
weaving machines?
What are we going to do?
How are we going to
prepare our students?
How are we going to organize
our research activities
to be competitive in this
rapidly changing world?
And I think this is
one way to do it.
Just a quick question.
I want to go back to the
OSIRIS-REx and the space topic.
OSIRIS-REx is, no
question, a home run.
But just like the
biomedical industry,
home runs in any of
these research areas
are few and far between.
So what are we doing,
if we want to remain
number one in the
space industry, what
are we doing to maintain,
look at the next opportunity
for that $100 million
project grant?
What do we need at the U
of A to maintain that level
of expertise and research?
Well, Dante brought me someone
who is a potential recruit
and hire.
And I don't say too much more
about it, but it would be--
actually, there are two recruits
that we were talking about.
We're already on to, for all of
those who are behind me who are
saying don't, don't.
Stop saying it.
Stop right there.
But there's some big
projects on the horizon,
and there are some key recruits
that I think we can make here
that would make us competitive.
The other thing is I think
that going forward, as I'll--
again, spoiler
alert for what I'm
going to talk about
in the next pillar--
is the opportunity to work with
NAU, and in particular, ASU
to come together.
Because as I've said,
we're too small to be
competing with each other.
We need to come together.
It's a good thing for the state.
We're part of the same
enterprise with this governing
board overseeing us.
And we have an opportunity to
come together with our sister
institutions to be very,
not only competitive,
but I think lead the world
in space exploration, space
science technologies, and
in particular the business
of space.
So I think those are
some of the things.
But the other thing is to have
a presence on the ground in DC.
We've moved one of our
incredible individuals
who've worked into the
Office of Research here.
Had them moved back to
DC to be close to NASA,
because he he's
an expert at NASA.
And he'd moved here.
We wanted to deploy
him back there
so we have someone on the
ground interacting with NASA.
We need someone on the
ground there working
with the NIH, the NSF,
and other agencies,
so we know what
these opportunities
are as they come down the
road, and be prepared for them.
I think for a $100 million
grant for the next things
that we know are
coming, we need to start
making investments a million
dollars to put together
teams that will help do
grant planning submission.
Getting all of our CVs together.
Pulling all of our preliminary
research data together.
The things that the three of
us have published together,
and make a compelling
argument about why
we're the place that should
be awarded that contract
and do that work.
Because the agency
has to have confidence
that they're making
a good investment.
Those are the kind
of things that I
think are going to help us
maintain our position in space.
Also, having the
telescopes and being
able to continue to have the
great weather that we have,
which I don't think is
going to change too much.
We've already got the
infrastructure here.
So having all those assets, but
aligning them and coordinating
them is going to be really key.
So I've got a
couple more slides.
And then I just wanted
to show validation.
We thought we were going to
be the first out of the chute
to say, this is such
an important area.
If you go back to the fourth
Industrial Revolution book,
all the stuff that's in there
are a part of this college.
But of course, we got scooped
by MIT a few weeks ago,
where they announced their big
college or program, school,
with a billion dollar backing.
So I don't think we're going
to have a billion dollars
to invest in this new college.
But certainly, we're
in good company
as being in the leaders in
this area around how we're
going to change the way we
educate the next generation
of students and do research.
Additionally, Berkeley
and Boston University
are onto this.
And the University of
Pittsburgh has a school
that was developed by one
of our former professors
who's now the dean
of that school.
And just like the
environment school
that I talked about earlier,
a college, one of our people
left to go to Washington
to start that college.
Be the founding dean.
We had another person who
worked in the environment
be recruited away from
the University of Michigan
to start an environmental
program there.
So I think that we're
onto the right thing.
And it certainly
fits with the theme
around the fourth
Industrial Revolution.
Importantly, this
idea came together,
and President Aoun in
his Robot-Proof book
coined the term humanics.
And I like that, because
it's the intersection.
And this fourth
Industrial Revolution talk
seems very stemish.
I would put an a in there and
say we're all about steam,
because the arts
are so important,
and they're going to
permeate almost everything we
do across this plan.
But the humanities,
we've already
talked about the
incredible importance
of general education.
And that's delivered
through the humanities.
And we've got
incredible programs
in writing, and philosophy, in
political science and policy.
And the idea of
bringing together
the physical, biological,
and digital sciences,
and what impact that's
going to have on society.
If you look in the fine print
of Professor Klaus's book,
he talks about the
good and the bad that
are going to happen with this
very rapid change in technology
and revolution that's going on.
I mean, we were
talking earlier about,
everybody has to
look at their thing.
Did you see that?
I'm just checking my phone
thinking that I was just--
no, I wasn't really
checking my phone.
But everybody is so
tied to these things.
And I think it's impaired
our cognitive ability
to remember things.
And it's certainly
changed interactions
of people having meaningful
conversations and debate,
and relationships.
So how do we weave that
part into this very techie
fourth Industrial
Revolution conversation?
Well, I think there are plenty
of examples and opportunities
for us to explore the intended
and unintended consequences
of this rapidly changing
world on society.
The moral issues, the ethics.
I mean, now, you can
send one discrete thing
to one person in the world,
and everybody in the world
at the same time on Instagram,
or whatever platform
you want to use.
So there are consequences.
And I think it's an
opportunity for us
to not only educate
our students,
but to also do discovery
and scholarship
around the intersection between
the humanities and science.
And then at the
bottom, of course,
there is the whole
idea of digital health
that I touched on earlier around
using artificial intelligence
and machine learning
algorithms to actually help
to take care of patients.
And not to replace
pathologists and radiologists,
but to help them to do
their job better and take
care of patients better.
So this is just a video that
shows two new buildings that we
discussed at the committee.
The first one is the Applied
Science Research Building,
where we'll do a lot of this
work that's translational--
translating
fundamental discovery
into commercializable products,
fulfilling one of our land
grant missions around
economic development,
because we'll spin
companies out.
And we've also invested
in establish UARC, which
is a ability for us,
and have a program where
we can get top secret
contracts from the government.
We didn't have that ability
until we established UARC.
And that program will be
located in this applied research
building with skiffs for
conversations that can only
be had if you have these very
high level, top level secret
security clearances.
And then, as we fly
across Speedway,
south of Speedway, in the
parking lot of the Optical
Science Building.
And for all of you who park
there for the basketball games,
just come see me.
I'll help you out.
But we're going to have a Grand
Challenges Building so that we
can do some of the work
around the College of Digital
Network and Computer
Science around having
fundamental discoveries
of bringing engineering
and optical science and
astronomy and health together
to make some of these
fundamental discoveries.
So this will be the
Grand Challenge Building.
It's envisioned to
be about 10 stories.
Will house all of
the things that
are in the strategic plan
around the research objectives.
And then the Applied
Science Building right next
to the aeronautical engineering.
Just north of Speedway,
and just southwest
of the Health Science Campus.
So we've got 20 more
minutes of questions
before we're
scheduled for a break.
RON SHOOPMAN: Oh,
the break is up now.
Oh, it's now.
BOARD MEMBER: It's now?
I'm behind.
I'm way behind.
[LAUGHTER]
LARRY PENLEY: You're
right on that.
We have more
time for questions.
Or we can shorten the break.
Well, let's take questions,
and see how long that takes.
Questions, comments
from the regents.
You know, I think you've done
an extraordinary job of bringing
us along in this process.
The time we spent
individually and collectively
with you has really prepared
us to hear what you're saying.
I found it to be extraordinarily
inspirational for me, because I
think we may not know
the how just yet,
but I see this as a living plan
that will take shape over time,
as your entire team grapples
with just how we execute this.
The fact that you brought
thousands of your university
faculty and the rest of the
team here together to have input
into this is really important.
Because as a leader, you
can't execute it alone.
It'll be executed by everybody
in this room, and everybody
watching university-wide.
And I think it's very exciting.
I commend you for the reach.
It's a tall order.
What you outlined
there is really
the old big, hairy,
audacious goal.
It's a BHAG, to say the least.
And I think that if
we can execute it,
it will separate
and identify U of A
as a leader in the
world in this area.
So my congratulations to you.
Well I appreciate
all your support.
But if you thought
that part was good,
come back after the break.
We've got really good stuff
later after the break.
And I know why.
I'm watching how
long it's taking.
We got started late.
RON SHOOPMAN: Yes No,
you did a fine job.
Any other questions or comments?
Regent Heiler, please.
JAY HEILER: Dr. Robbins,
don't worry about the time.
It's not dragging.
It's very engaging.
And we appreciate it, and it
is an impressive compilation
up to this point.
One specific question that
I'd like you to address.
In your thinking about
advancing the student experience
and the undergraduate
offering at the university,
at the same time, you're
going to reestablish it
as a leading
research institution
and take the research
budget up to $800 million.
What is your
construct for how you
intend to pursue both those
things at the same time, when
in the traditional
paradigms, they're thought
to be at odds with one another?
So what is your thinking
about that as you go forward?
Well I don't think
it's an either/or.
I think these are two
fundamental missions
that we have.
And as we were talking about,
President Crow was talking
about, it's not either/or.
It's both/and.
Yes.
We're going to get to yes.
We're going to do both of these.
They're both
critically important.
And as we shared
with you yesterday,
there'll be a process that
we'll go through to triage
and prioritize different
initiatives from different
of the pillars.
And some of which,
we've already started.
The others are low risk,
high impact investments
that we can make
immediately, and we
have some funds
that are set aside
for strategically starting to
invest in those projects now.
The next level and
the next tranche
will be really dependent on
how we can reallocate resources
that are currently being
deployed across the university.
And we're going to have to
have a discussion around RCM
and any modifications
that could be
made to that budgetary process.
And then finally,
there are many things
in this plan that are going
to be revenue-positive for us,
and give us new resources
to invest in programs that
will help our students be
successful, or do research
and give us an advantage
to get the discoveries made
better and faster.
But one of the key parts
of this, of course,
will be one of
the things that we
talked about even in
the interview process,
is a fundraising campaign.
And we raised more
money last year
than any other single year in
the history of the university.
Over $300 million.
And JP Roczniak and his
team, and the deans,
and people who have spent
years developing relationships
and presenting inspiring
opportunities for investment
from donors are to
be congratulated
for that accomplishment.
We're going to have
to do better than
that every year for
this next campaign
to be able to have the
resources to fund this plan.
But it'll be a combination
of all of those.
And we'll have discussions
from the senior leaders,
the deans, and the
implementation team about how
we pick and choose in a timely
and efficient and smart way
which initiatives that we
will deploy assets to as time
goes on.
But we intend to get
to all 90 of the things
that we've talked about.
Now, there's even
an initiative--
forgotten what number it is.
I was going to memorize it.
There is an initiative
for new initiatives
so that this plan can
continue to be organic,
and flexible, and interactive.
If there are people who
come to the university,
or people who have not been
as involved as they thought,
if you have a new idea, then you
can come to the implementation
group and pitch this idea.
And maybe we won't do a couple
of the other initiatives,
but some of these
new initiatives.
RON SHOOPMAN: Other comments
or questions before the break.
Regent Taylor Robson.
KARRIN TAYLOR ROBSON:
Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
I just want to add
to your comment
about the success of
this strategic plan
really stemming from President
Robbins' engagement of so
many people, the
thousands of people
here at the
university community.
But also this board.
Not only this board as a
whole, but each one of us
individually have been asked
to engage and have engaged.
And I think that
will go a long way
to a successful
implementation of the plan.
At the end of the
day, people support
what they help to create.
And so you certainly are
off on the right foot.
The other thing--
teams of people
that are engaged in this,
they seek leadership,
and they respond to leadership.
And your leadership in
this is really palpable.
And the clarity that you
in this plan are providing
will be very helpful
as you move forward
for the implementation of it.
And the metrics.
Metrics are obviously
very important.
It's the benchmark from which
this board will watch you
as you implement this,
and as you succeed,
as undoubtedly you will.
So congratulations.
I'll have more to say after
your next few pillars,
but I think you're
off to a great start.
So thank you.
Thank you.
And, we listen.
We've listened to each
and every one of you.
Regent Manson, the last
time we met with her,
she said, you know,
I mentioned to you
before that there's
nothing about the new vet
school in here.
And I see that
there's still not.
And I think now
there's something
in here about the vet school.
Because we're all
excited about that.
It's just that we're going--
there's so many things
moving very rapidly.
And obviously, it's a
big part of the plan.
But I think people around
campus, when we've asked them,
first of all, they sometimes
have issues with what's in
or what's not in the plan.
And we said instead
of, well, get in line,
or send us something, come
in and let's talk about it.
And hours and hours and hours of
discussions and deliberations.
And many of the things
have been changed.
And I think probably the
biggest changes have been
when we listen to students.
And there's no perfect plan.
And this obviously will continue
to evolve and get better.
But having the students
involved and telling us,
if we're going to
be student-centric
for this university, we need
to know what the students want,
and what they need.
And to help them be successful
one student at a time.
RON SHOOPMAN: Regent Meyers.
Yeah.
You know, I appreciate one of
the underpinning principles
of this is leveraging place.
And I've often felt that
one of the important aspects
of the place we live
is our military.
And we have a great asset of
the Army down in Fort Huachuca
down in Sierra Vista,
with their major focus
on intelligence operations.
And as I look at this
new school of data,
I like seeing the
word cybersecurity.
I mean, it's not all
about fighting wars,
but it's preventing wars.
And I think there's so
much U of A could do.
And I think it's maybe been
an under-realized opportunity
to work with the military,
and to help our place,
but also do research in
fundamental areas that
will help protect our nation
and prevent war in the world.
Yeah.
And, I've had the opportunity
to go to U of A Sierra Vista,
and see our cybersecurity
program there
and what Jason Dunham
has done there.
I think it's going
to be a critical part
of this new college, If
we can get it executed.
And people like Jason.
We just recognized him at
the last football game.
He's clearly one of the
leaders in education
around cybersecurity.
And it's because he worked so
closely with the Fort there.
So we've got a lot
of opportunity.
And I think that
times are exciting.
The world is changing very
rapidly, as I keep saying.
But the idea that you
can pay your income
tax in Arizona using
bitcoin or cryptocurrency.
I mean, who knew?
This is a very
progressive state.
I think it's a pioneering
entrepreneurial state.
I keep saying, I spent time
in California and Texas.
And this is sort of the
perfect blend and perfect place
to be a leader.
Certainly around
higher education
and economic development
for the state,
particularly around
health sciences and space.
I was very impressed with what
you told us, I think, probably
even in committee meetings,
that just because one
of the great programs at
the University of Arizona
didn't make the plan in terms
of what's being presented today
doesn't diminish its importance.
Getting everybody
involved and recognizing
that all of these folks,
regardless of whether they're
listed on the plan or
not, are key to the future
of the University of Arizona.
This will take leadership
at every level.
It can't be done by this board.
For certain, we will approve
it, and support it, and do
what we can to make it happen.
But it will really be the
team under your leadership
that gets it done.
And I think you're off
to a great start of not
making people feel like
they're a loser in the plan.
Because your emphasis that
we're building on the success
that we have rather
than deciding
who's a loser in the plan.
We'll win going
forward together,
is a very important
message for your team.
Yeah, I appreciate that.
And the one thing
I keep saying is,
if you can't find yourself being
excited about student success,
you're in the wrong place.
So that's the most
important part of this plan,
and my opinion, is
getting the resources
and developing the programs,
and just changing the culture
and the mindset of service.
I heard Paul talk this
morning at the breakfast,
and he said exactly what
I've always thought.
When you use to go in these
classes in medical schools.
Look to your right
and look to your left.
There's only going
to be one of you
left at the end of this course.
And Paul said what
I've always thought,
which comes from the
Positive Coaching Alliance.
If any one of my
students fail, it's
my fault. It's not their fault.
I didn't do a good enough job
to help them be successful.
I think that cultural
shift in our mentality
across this campus could help us
to be really transformational.
For no matter who the student
is, where they come from,
once they're part of our family,
we're their surrogate family,
it's our job to help
them be successful,
no matter what we have
to do to help them.
Now we've got finite resources
and limited resources.
But I think just having
that mind shift, the idea.
I've always said about the
Ritz Carlton, it's their job.
If you stop anybody in
a Ritz Carlton and say,
can you tell me how to
get to this place or that?
It's their job to help you.
And I think that that's part of
what this cultural shift will
be here I was incredibly
impressed by-- there were
seven deans from law schools
across the country who
came and gave me a report, a
remarkable report on what Dean
Miller and his colleagues
at the law school are doing.
And at a time when people were
challenging me when I got here.
So are you going to
close the law school?
Because you know
law schools are--
with all due respect, Regent
Ridenour-- law schools
are a thing of the
past, and all that.
Well of course we're
not going to close it.
So it gave me incredible hope
about the future of our law
school.
But the thing that I
was most impressed about
is that the students really
had no real negative comments
about the college in things.
And pointed out that even
the custodial staff would
stop and ask the students,
how are you doing today?
Is it going all right?
How can I help you?
We're pulling for you.
That kind of pride.
And I think that's why a lot of
people stay at the university.
They could make more
money other places,
but they want to be
part of something that's
bigger than themselves.
And the thing that
helps us to achieve
that is if for our students
go out and be successful.
If our research
projects succeed,
and we discover new knowledge,
and we come up with a new drug
to treat cancer
better, whatever it is.
That's the kind of spirit
I think that this plan has
the opportunity to achieve.
Along those great
words, I think
it's appropriate to
end this first session.
If you are ready to do
that, Mr. President.
ROBERT ROBBINS: I'm ready.
Yes, sure.
We have some lunch for
regents in the next 25 minutes.
Or 20 minutes or so.
Let's try to be back to
start right on time at 11:30.
Thank you for your attention
for the wonderful presentation.
We'll continue
here in 20 minutes.
Thank you.